دمرت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزلا
لعائله ابو السبح في منطقه البصه في دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه ما ادى الى سقوط
شهيدين على الاقل واستهدفت قوات الاحتلال
المنزل بصاروخين اطلق من طائره حربيه
انفجر احدهما بينما لم ينفجر الصاروخ
الثاني الصحفي اشرف ابو عمرا ينقل لنا
الصوره من مكان
الاستهداف يحاول المواطنون هنا ايضا
استخراج ما تبقى من اثاث داخل هذا المنزل
وذكريات لهم بعد ان دمر الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
هذا المنزل بشكل كامل هنا في
منطقه البصه في بدير البلح وهي الصاروخ
اللي ما انفجر الاول صاروخ انضرب على
البيت خبط عمل ثغره في
الدار مكان الدرج وصالون
وظلوا في الاتجاه هذا ونزل هنا في عند
الجرا هذا هذا
صاروخ هذا الصاروخ الذي سقط على المنزل
عائله ابو السبح في اللحظات الاولى ولم
ينفجر فخرج عدد من افراد العائله ومن ثم
سقط الصاروخ الاخر ولكن هذه الجزئيه من
الصاروخ يبدو بانه من طائرات الاف 16
الاسرائيليه التي اغارت على المنزل ودمرته
بشكل كامل بالاضافه الى عدد من منازل
المواطنين المجاوره لعائله ابو السباح e